[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Siebers in
allen guten Abend es ist jedes Mal wie
ein Reflex nach einer furchtbaren Tat
folgt die Diskussion wie so etwas in
Zukunft zu verhindern sei nach dem
Amoklauf von Hamburg mit acht Toten gibt
es eine ganze Reihe von Forderungen
weniger Waffen bessere Überprüfungen nun
läuft die Diskussion um ein schärferes
Waffenrecht in Deutschland ja schon
länger Gegner einer Verschärfung
argumentieren damit wäre Hamburg nicht
zu verhindern gewesen Befürworter
fürchten dass die Diskussion auch jetzt
ein Reflex bleibt ohne echte Folgen
Annegret Oster
auch heute bringen Menschen Blumen und
Kerzen zum Gebetshaus der Zeugen Jehovas
mehr als 100 mal feuert Philipp F mit
seiner halbautomatischen Pistole in die
Gemeinde tötet sieben Menschen bevor er
sich selbst erschießt viel Anteilnahme
aber auch viel Unverständnis über das
geltende Waffenrecht wichtig sei dass
man da
bisschen mehr hinschaut nicht auch mit
dem Besitz der Waffen zu Hause ich
Schützenvereine sagen wir machen es aus
Sport und so aber eine Waffe ist eine
Waffe also ich bin dafür dass das jetzt
auf jeden Fall verschärft hat ja die
Debatte über einen verschärftes
Waffenrecht ist längst entbrannt ein
verschärfter Gesetzentwurf liegt bereits
vor der angesichts des jüngsten
Attentats weiter
verschärft werden soll also wir werden
das sicher diskutieren der Gesetzentwurf
ist aufgrund der Tatsache dass die
halbautomatischen Langwaffen in Halle
und in Hanau benutzt wurden entstanden
es ist ja erst ein Entwurf insofern
werden wir das natürlich jetzt prüfen
laut dieses Gesetzentwurfs sollen
Behörden kün ftig leichter untereinander
Informationen austauschen können zum
Beispiel wenn ein Sportschütze umzieht
bei der persönlichen Prüfung muss die
Polizei Dienststelle vor Ort beteiligt
sein auch Gesundheitsämter sollen
relevante Informationen weitergeben
und wer zum ersten Mal eine
waffenrechtliche Erlaubnis beantragt
soll dafür ein fachärztliches oder
fachpsychologisches Zeugnis vorlegen
müssen bislang brauchen über 25-jährige
diesen Nachweis nicht
mit diesen Plänen hatte die
Innenministerin die Verbände der Jäger
und Sportschützen gegen sich aufgebracht
der Koalitionspartner FDP leistet
Schützenhilfe wir haben ein Waffengesetz
das verbietet dass Menschen die
psychisch krank sind eine Waffe haben
genau das ist der Fall in Hamburg
vorgelegen hat die Waffenbehörde wusste
sogar davon und deswegen gilt in der
jetzigen Situation so kurz nach einer so
schrecklichen Tat Zurückhaltung
Aufarbeitung und dann einen Plan zu
machen damit sowas in Zukunft nicht noch
mal passiert auch waffenexperten sehen
die Probleme nicht in Gesetzestexten
sondern in deren Anwendung
600 verschiedene Behörden in der
bundesrepublikenrecht zuständig um
diesen voll zu kümmern das ist
vollkommen unbefriedigen und schafft
riesengroße Lücken die dann solche Taten
von Hamburg überhaupt
ob und in welcher Weise die Tat von
Hamburg das deutsche Waffenrecht
verändert darüber wird am Mittwoch im
Innenausschuss diskutiert werden
Millionen toter Fische es war wie aus
einem Horrorfilm aber es war Realität an
der Oder letzten Sommer im Grenzfluss
zwischen Deutschland und Polen und
vielleicht noch verstörender es könnte
wieder passieren denn weder ist der
Verursacher klar ermittelt noch gibt es
echte Konsequenzen um eine neue
dramatische über Salzung des Flusses zu
verhindern und die Zeit bis zum nächsten
Sommer wird knapp Katrin Lindner
normalerweise fährt Rolf Müller auch im
Winter Fischen doch er und seine
Brandenburger Kollegen haben beschlossen
die Tiere bis zur leichte Saison im Mai
zu schonen zu hoch waren die Verluste im
Sommer wenigstens ist keine Art komplett
verschwunden der Fischbestand hat sich
sicherlich halbiert
aber
er hat auch ein hohes
reproduktionspotenzial so das war in
zwei drei Jahren eigentlich davon
ausgehen können dass sich das alles
wieder eingepegelt hat und der alte
Fischbestand sich wieder aufgebaut hat
in der oder starben massenweise Fische
schätzungsweise 1000 Tonnen eingeleitet
Salz auf polnische Seite in Kombination
mit hohen Temperaturen und Niedrigwasser
gelten als Ursache dadurch konnte die
Gold Alge wachsen die Gift absonderte
doch Wissenschaftler warnen der
Salzgehalt in der oder ist seit der
Katastrophe nicht wesentlich gesunken
wenn wir wieder nie durch Wasser haben
und wenn sich an den Einheit in der
Praxis in Polen nichts ändert dann ist
es durchaus wahrscheinlich dass wir
wieder Massenentwicklung dieser Alge
haben und möglicherweise produziert die
dann auch wieder viel Gift dazu kommt
die oder ist anfälliger geworden ihr
fehlen nun 60% der Muscheln die nicht
mehr Wasserfiltern können so die
Wissenschaftler und die eigene liebten
schon im Fluss
Greenpeace geht nach Auswertung von
Wasserproben davon aus dass drei
Bergwerke zweier polnische Konzerne im
Süden Polens mit ihren Abwässern
Auslöser für das Fischsterben waren doch
nach wie vor ist kein Verursacher
ermittelt polnische umweltschützer
fordern schnelles Handeln schon damals
wir wollen einen sofortigen Stopp der
salzeinleitung dieses Abwasser muss
entsalzt werden natürlich fordert
niemand dass die Minen geschlossen
werden aber es sollen Systeme und
Technologien zu Entsalzung von
minenwasser eingesetzt werden und wir
wollen dass die Abwassereinleitung von
der aktuellen Strömung des Flusses
abhängig gemacht wird
seit Januar hat Deutschland den Vorsitz
bei der Kommission zum Schutz der oder
es wird verhandelt grenzübergreifend
nicht einfach aus deutscher Sicht
müssten halt die salzeinleitung in
diesen kritischen Zeiten reduziert oder
eingestellt werden das kann aber nur
Polen prüfen und entscheiden weil das
auf deren Territorium ist
Rolf Müller wünscht sich das
wirtschaftliche Interessen hinten
angestellt werden diesmal müsste die
Natur Vorfahrt haben
natürlich ein großer
Produktionspotenzial aber wenn so ein
Fischsterben jedes Jahr passiert dann
ist irgendwann
Ende
er weiß Temperatur und Niedrigwasser
kann bis zum Sommer keiner beeinflussen
einzig und allein den Salzgehalt in der
oder
ja da ist die Basis eines ganzen
Ökosystems eingegangen was muss noch
passieren damit die Nachbarn Deutschland
und Polen gemeinsam eine neue
Katastrophe verhindert
die Übersicht über weitere wichtige
Nachrichten an diesem Samstag hast du
jetzt Hannah die Deutsche Post und die
Gewerkschaft wer die haben sich auf
einen neuen Tarifvertrag geeinigt die
vierte Verhandlungsrunde hat den
Durchbruch gebracht unbefristete Streiks
dürften damit vom Tisch sein die rund
160.000 Beschäftigten der Post bekommen
ab April 2024 340 Euro mehr im Monat da
Post entspricht das seinen
durchschnittlichen Lohnplus von
11,5%. hinzu kommt eine Sonderzahlung
von insgesamt 3000 Euro über 15 Monate
die Laufzeit beträgt 24 Monate
an einigen deutschen Flughäfen wird
dagegen am Montag wieder gestreikt und
zwar in Berlin Hamburg Hannover und
Bremen hier müssen sich Zehntausende
Passagiere auf längere Wartezeiten und
Flugausfälle einstellen wer die hat
unter anderem das Sicherheitspersonal
und die Beschäftigten der
Bodenverkehrsdienste zur
Arbeitsniederlegung aufgerufen
die katholische Reformbewegung synodaler
Weg hat heute nach dreieinhalb Jahren
ihre Arbeit abgeschlossen am letzten Tag
der 5 synodalversammlung wurden noch
mehrere Beschlüsse gefasst die
Delegierten stimmten mit großer Mehrheit
für eine veränderten Umgang mit
geschlechtlicher Vielfalt in der Kirche
und sprachen sich zudem für die Weihe
von Frauen zu Diakoninnen aus der
Vorsitzende der Deutschen
Bischofskonferenz Bischof betzing zog
insgesamt ein positives Fazit die
Präsidentin des Zentralkomitees
deutscher katholikenstädter Karp
erklärte sie hätte sich ohne Zweifel
mehr gewünscht
zum zweiten Mal hat heute der nationale
Gedenktag für die Opfer terroristischer
Gewalt stattgefunden bei der zentralen
Gedenkveranstaltung in Berlin sagte als
bundespräsident Gauck
opfer und Angehörige dürften nicht
allein gelassen werden der
opferbeauftragte der Bundesregierung
kobamante das Staat Gesellschaft und
Behörden lernen müssten einfühlsamer und
angemessener mit den Betroffenen
umzugehen
knapp zwei Wochen nach dem verheerenden
Bootsunglück sind heute an Italiens
Küste mehr als 1.300 geflüchtete an Land
gebracht worden darunter fast 500
Menschen die in der Nacht auf einem
Fischerboot die süditalienische Stadt
Crotone erreichtten die Zahl der
geflüchteten die Italien in diesem Jahr
bisher über das Mittelmeer erreicht
haben ist fast dreimal so hoch wie im
gleichen Zeitraum 2022
heute kommt aus London die Eilmeldung
der Generaldirektor der BBC sagt er
werde nicht zurücktreten
was ist da passiert die wichtigste
fußballsendung im britischen Fernsehen
muss heute ohne Moderation und Experten
gesendet werden weil die BBC ihren
bestbezahlten Moderator suspendiert
hatte und aus Solidarität mit ihm auch
niemand anderes einspringen will Gary
Lineker legendärer Fußballstar ist seit
über 20 Jahren Gesicht der Sendung und
er hat nie mit seiner politischen
Meinung hinterm Berg gehalten die BBC
Chefs sehen jetzt aber eine rote Linie
überschritten justin herlein hat mehr
dazu aus London
alte Liebe rostet nicht statt sich auf
die traditionelle Fußball
Samstagabend-Show match of the day
vorzubereiten ging starmoderator Gary
leneker heute selbst ins Stadion und
zwar zu seinem ersten und weiterhin
Lieblingsverein lässt der City
nachdem die BBC Lineker gestern Abend
suspendierte findet match of the day
heute ohne ihn statt welcher Form und ob
überhaupt war lange im Unklaren nachdem
seine beiden expertenkollegen Ian right
und allen Shira sich solidarisch
erklärten und ankündigten dann würden
sie auch nicht mitmachen
Auslöser des Konflikts ist ein Tweet
linekers in dem er eine Gesetzesvorlage
zur Bekämpfung illegaler Einwanderung
mittels kleiner Boote über den
Ärmelkanal kritisierte zur Abschreckung
sollen den Asylsuchenden bei Ankunft auf
der Insel jegliche Rechte entzogen
werden lenneka kommentierte dies unter
anderem mit der Aussage die Sprache mit
der die konservative Regierung für die
Gesetzgebung werbe sei der in
Deutschland der 30er Jahre nicht
unähnlich die seit schweren Einklang zu
bringen mit Regularien der
Unparteilichkeit des Senders erklärte
die BBC eine unserer gründungsstatuten
ist Unparteilichkeit und die wollen wir
liefern allerdings unterliegt als
Sportmoderator nicht denselben
Richtlinien wie im Nachrichtenbereich
tätige und als ein gewisser Ernst sugar
Moderator der ebenfalls sehr bekannten
BBC Sendung die prank ist sich bei den
letzten Wahlen im Netz gegen den
Kandidaten der Oppositionspartei
aussprach wurde der nicht suspendiert
wir nicht zum ersten Mal erleben schadet
der BBC es schadet ihrem Ruf der
Unparteilichkeit und ist beschädigt das
Vertrauen in die BBC die Rundfunkanstalt
muss sich inzwischen des Vorwurfs
erwehren dass hier mit zweierlei Maß
gemessen werde und man sich dem Druck
der konservativen Regierungspartei beuge
bekannt ist in diesem Zusammenhang auch
die noch nicht abschließend geklärte
Auseinandersetzung um den Vorsitzenden
des Senders Richard Sharp ihm wird
vorgeworfen dem damaligen
Premierminister Boris Johnson bei der
Vermittlung eines 800.000 Pfund
Darlehens geholfen zu haben und zwar
bevor ihm der Prestige und
einflussreiche Posten zu Teil wurde
erfährt unterdessen eine Welle der
Solidarität und das nicht nur seitens
seiner Fernsehkollegen und ich kann
nicht den Grund erkennen warum man
jemand für diese Aussage sollte
vielleicht ist das hier ein
Sprachproblem aber ich sehe das nicht
der Wunsch der BBC sich mit ihrem Star
Kommentator über seine twittertätigkeit
auseinanderzusetzen erscheint durchaus
verständlich die möglichen Folgen seiner
Suspendierung nicht abzusehen ist jedoch
eine schwere Panne die der alten Dame
BBC nun mindestens eine Menge Sport
eingebracht hat
jenseits von lenneker und seiner Sendung
die britische Innenministerin sagt über
ihre asylpläne selbst dass diese mit
hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit nicht mit der
Europäischen Menschenrechtskonvention
vereinbar sein man Reize mit dem
Vorhaben die Grenzen internationalen
Rechts aus
nochmal
und da blicken wir so wie jeden Samstag
an dieser Stelle auf die gewinnzahlen
vom Lotto und die lauten
17/20 22 23 27 32 Superzahl 7 alle
Angaben wie immer ohne Gewähr
fehlt noch der Blick aufs ziemlich
durchwachsene Wetter in den kommenden
Tagen morgen überquert uns Regen nach
Nordosten in den zentralen
Mittelgebirgen fällt Schnee maximal drei
bis 15 Grad in den nächsten Tagen bleibt
es ungemütlich nass am Montag erreicht
uns ein Sturmtief dabei wird es bis zu
21 Grad warm danach wieder kühler
sie hat es getan die beste Skiläuferin
dieser Welt michaela shiffrin hat ihren
sieben und 80
Weltcup-Sieg geholt das hat vor ihr
keine und keiner geschafft freuen Sie
sich auf mehr dazu gleich im Aktuellen
Sportstudio und freuen Sie sich auf
bundesliga
[Musik]